Hi. Hello.
Hi.
Um
We're gathered here today to play a game called happy wheels. I have to get on a plane...
in...
3 hours and 35 minutes (OMG moo man then why u play)
Cough/laugh
When I said be ready for anything
I don't think you guys were expecting this but I am gonna play this
Honestly and truly how is it changed since the last time that I played it?
Not that much apparently. When was the last time I played? Hang on.
So the last time I played it was October 2016, which is almost three years ago now. Oh wait. No, um, the the
Super secret quiet (SEIZURE) the quietest. Let's play I did (DOUBLE SEIZURE) I did a couple times in there, but it's been a while
I actually did before I started doing highlights. I did one that was 6 YEAR, Master of Ba-ha-ha-lls! ...
Uh, Mark?
*Silent appreciation*
That's hilarious...
So we're gonna play an honest-to-goodness (wait, what)
We're gonna we're gonna honestly goodnessly (is that a word?) we're honest and we're good in that
We are going to play this game and we're gonna be honest and good about it when we play it
So put on your honest hats and put on your good pants -( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)- because we're about to play happy wheels
Yay!
I don't mean for it to sound sarcastic...
I'm actually excited about when I heard the music kick on I was like, oh, yeah!
(Short laugh) It's been so long...
So I think we can go by top rated of this month and just see what happens cuz it's been so...
long it's been so...
long, I don't Oh
Click here... click...
Click, what?
Like, flick it... ok, jump, crouch. I, amazingly stiff legs like I remember, amazingly I remember.
Wow, now this is something special
I mean, it's very impressive but this isn't exactly... GAME!??!
Mario, Look out! (sarcasm is in effect)
It's very impressive let me, let me just say that straight up, it's very impressive on a technical perspective
but it is it's it's not... (you said it was, WHAT IS IT MARK!?!?!)
This isn't fun, (laughter encounters)
I don't want to be rude by real, (AAAH!) Oh, yeah... I don't want to be rude about it, But oh...
You're so nice though you're so I hope you liked it and have a nice day. Thanks anonymous, I guess
That's the first one I come to
The top rated of this month I you know, I can't fault it
I cannot fault it. You know that was not bad shooting stars music. This is my first music level a music level a
Music level click on the Boop. Oh
Yeah, oh
Wow, oh I can't leave
(WTF JUST HAPPENED?)
(silent laugh/cough)
Oh no, oh no, what has Happy Wheels become (laugh)
What has happened to happy wheels in my absence, I love it
I love it. I love it a lot
I can't fault it at all in any way, shape, or form. I cannot fault that
I can't fault it a fat bat lady
snatches your baby in a cave
*bat person takes kid*
Oh
(Laughter) You weren't lying...
You're not lying about a thing
You were like, hey, at least I get to play. Hey, that's pretty good, right? Watch out. All right, here we go. All right
Oww...
This is great
Like I'm not mocking it like honestly like
There there's there is a reason why happy wheels is so popular is because it's just like it is fun.
Oh hey, you killed my son!
Im gonna
What
That's amazing. Oh shit. Okay. All right. Well, made that. All right. Can I get up here? Thank you. Thank you. Thank you
Thank you, please thank you. Thank you. Thank you. At least I remember how to play amazingly. I remember there's no escape now. Oh
My son might have been alive
That's really impressive I gotta admit
They even got the shading on the eyes the pupils of the eyes have shading. Look at this layer
That's amazing. This is incredible what happened to happy wheels when I was away?
Don't move short... Oh, I love it. Don't move. Oh, yeah. This is still a classic. I'm not moving
I'd never move. Why would I move?
This is all very impressive very very improosive (what?)
All right
The level of quality of don't moves has diminished I will just I will just say that it has
diminished
Pogo fight
Ohhh
Rate 5 and nothing will happen seriously quit it. Great. Hi, Timmy
Bye Timmy
Bye Billy. Mark?? Hey, wait a minute. Santa? Ow-ho-ho-hu-hu-hu
Ah, shit I died. Time to try again
Ya know I'm not laughing because like I find the physics humorous and it is it like it is well
Fuck. I like I-I it-it does still have charm to it even to this day
I'm laughing because of like all of these memories of like play I've played this game for hou-
why is tha-a-a-at
I've played this game for hundreds of hours
And the amazing thing about is like these things can happen new that you've never seen before
Like alright, cool, good. Things can happen that you've still never seen before
(Defeated wheeze of laughter)
It's just like, it's so surreal, like I thought I'd left this part of me behind
I thought you know, when you grow up you put your child
Sorry what
Ohh
When you grow up, you put your childish things away and you
you move on, and you you move on with your life and you-y-y-you get oww you get good and
you know, everything, you know y-you grow up, but you know to come back to its really I
don't know wholesome. I don't think wholesome is the right word when things like this are happening, but
Wholesome. I'm a-go with wholesome
N-
My buttocks
Alright good got that dislodged. All right, Santa take a back foot
Oww
How does that pierce me through the flat of the handle?
Yaaa
NO. NO. NO. Ah haa-ha ha ha ha
Got ya in the a-oh
Oh, come on you asshole get out of here
aahhAHHH
I'm falling back into the same whole-
Like it's weird it's like I'm in a behavior loop where I
Ah fucking come on! I can totally see like how every single nook and cranny of me playing this before I
Just gotta get oh no
Fucking co-ha-HAA. All right, come on. Ah
I'm gonna get you. Get out of here with that doOOH. Oh, don't okay
Santa has been disarmed. All I must do is get up here. Oh
(Look of complete fear)
Up, okay, oh, nOAAH, NO, NO, WAIT, NOOO!
AHH FUCK, COME ONNN!
Take this, Billy, Mark, me
(Unintelligible) deflect with my butt!
NO Santa, don't!
He's really pointing it at me
So it's a standoff, is it? Hi-yah, Ima dance on your corpse big guy
Oh no, oh no, I didn't really mean I dance... I didn't really mean it, I DIDN'T MEAN IT!
Come on, I made it! Noooooo... You asshole... You asshole...
GudFookingDamitt. Damn it. Damn you. All right cool. Cool. DOOOOH
If this bat, if this axe, if this back axe, god FUCK-ING
I'm alive? No, I'm not alive. That was Santa. Oh
OHHH god. I just, I thought you know
This would be a fun
revisit to Happy Wheels and I would just be like (unintelligible) playing a game that
I played before, and everything would be fine and, and neat.
AHHHH
i am really trying! I am really trying! (oh, are you now?)
I am really trying, I'm really trying, I'm really trying
Right up the balls...
Why is that trapped up there?
I feel like things didn't necessarily get so trapped as they-they are now. Oh, no, no, no Sant- not like this not like this
Okay, alright it's okay, alright
Santa just, oh no Santa's caught on the ax in my dick?!
Are you kidding me?!
Okay, there we go, there we go, there we go, just gotta get out of here
Oh my god, really? Ah, not my dick
My poor abused peen! Okay, here we go. There we go, just gotta scooch. All right, it's fine. There we go.
(Defeated laugh)
I hate
Nothing, this is grea-a-at
All right, that is enough
That's enough. I am limited time. (You're what?) It's it's fun. Look. That's the thing. It's fun. It's weird being back
It's weird playing it again, cuz it's still fun. Like the levels are, are, are
hit or miss (tik tok lord here) but uh, you know
It's still fun and to know
It's good to know that people are still making so I am out of time because I've been so swamped with
post-production on the big project yada yada
I can't say much but it's just like
Everyday, we have to do a little something more and then the other day we're filming pickups and that took all day
And now I have to go to Cincinnati and I don't want to talk about why I'm going to Cincinnati
But I've just been very busy, but I'm having fun, and at the end of the day
That's what YouTube should be about is having fun
So if that means that I got to blow my ass up on Happy Wheels all over again
Then I guess I'm happy to do that. So thank you everybody so much for watching
I have done way too many episodes of happy wheels, but it's all in a playlist
So if you want to see more and you want to see me
evolve over the years
Go check out the playlist, link in the description below
Thank you everybody so much for watching, if you want me to play more Happy Wheels,
(intro music begins) I-I don't know shout as loud as you can the comments tell me down there. Hey, I don't know maybe
See, no promises, no promises at all. But thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always, I will see you in the next video buh-bye!
(Crazy La Paint at full volume)